we work in a world of imagination as
humans we're always projecting ourselves
onto any characters that we see
we may see lightning mcqueen
as a car but we're still interpreting
that as owen wilson as a white male it's
always really striking to me that we can
imagine talking cars but we can't
imagine female nascar racers
it feels like we should be able to do
this we should be able to do this but
representation in the movie industry has
been an ongoing fight the world of
animation is no different according to a
report by the usc annenberg inclusion
initiative only 17 of 120 recent
animated films featured female
characters as the lead or co-lead and
only 39 of 100 recent animated tv series
featured a largely female cast disney
touts itself as a progressive and
diverse company studies from their 2021
fiscal year show their ongoing stride
for diversity in the workplace but this
specific problem is less about the
people behind the screen and more so
about the characters and speaking lines
in animation
my goal is to kind of normalize seeing
diversity on screen being able to
present that on a large scale is
incredible
[Music]
this is jessica height the department
manager of feature films at pixar
before managing the art department her
work and discoveries at pixar changed
the way in which scripts were digested
several years ago i started a program
or a process of tracking gender across
our characters and sort of trying to
work with increasing screen
representation and diversity on screen
i got started in theater i worked at a
theater called the magic theater in san
francisco because we were a smaller
theater we were able to be a lot more
diverse in our choices
i know personally as a director i was
absolutely drawn to those stories my
transition to pixar actually came
directly from theater because mary
coleman who had been the associate
artistic director at the magic theater
had transitioned over to pixar she would
bring me in to do script coverage which
was basically reading scripts and
writing analysis the continuous reading
writing and analyzing surprised jessica
after she noticed one major commonality
i first noticed that there was a
discrepancy between the male and female
characters when i was working on cars 3.
what i was sort of feeling was that oh
this feels very uneven and so i went in
and actually counted the difference and
at that point it was 90 male and only 10
female it was so stark it became
something that i think i was unable to
step away from and say
you know this isn't a problem i had gone
back and tracked the data across all of
our films at that point uh where we were
was about 75 male for speaking
characters and for the line count take a
look at pixar's earlier movies and one
of their most popular franchises toy
story with the exception of andy's mom
sister and beau peep virtually all of
the characters and speaking lines are
predominantly male
when i finally was able to present this
to the executives i did it with a
collection of charts and graphs
because for me being able to take the
emotion out of what we were doing and to
just be able to have them look at the
numbers and it was irrefutable
i remember being absolutely terrified in
that meeting of just you know
handing them out and
wondering what people were going to say
as this room um of of all of the top
execs where we're in there looking at it
not only were the executives open to
hearing about jessica's discoveries but
they immediately put a plan in action
working together to come up with a
solution
as a studio we have the the gift really
of working with these incredible
technical minds as well as these
storytellers and so every time you come
up with an idea of like oh here's
something i would like to change
a technical wizard will come in and say
oh i can create a tool for that to make
it really easy and really scalable
i had some incredible allies the biggest
and most amazing one being josh miner
who is in our tools department he was
thinking about it from a technical point
of view of like is there something that
we can be doing as an organization that
might be able to address these problems
and it was really josh that said hey we
can use this tool that we already have
in pixar that we use as script
supervisors to track data
now this is something that the
executives the producers the directors
anyone on any of the creatives on any of
our movies are now expecting this
information and it becomes part of the
conversation at every brain trust in
2019 pixar created spark shorts a series
of short animated films designed to give
women and people of color more
opportunities in animation there was
really a space where the cultural moment
outside of me outside of pixar really
shifted and i feel like the momentum
of that was really something that helped
ricochet the work that we're doing into
the sort of level that we're able to do
right now black lives matter and me too
were those cultural moments that
catapulted a shift towards producing
more diverse and inclusive movies pixar
films like coco and soul show the level
of success when diversity and
representation are showcased and look at
the cast of toy story 4. fast forward
through the franchise and we see the
introduction and inclusion of characters
like mrs potato head jessie dolly and
characters like bo peep were given more
meaningful roles in the main narrative
in animation it takes so long to make
our films so
we are finally starting to see the
receipts of the work that got started in
2016 you know in 2017 when we really as
a studio started paying close attention
as you see the next films coming out
you're gonna be seeing a lot more
diversity on the screen
i also think that we're starting to see
more women more people of color more
more people in the creative spaces that
are creating and i think that naturally
leads to more diverse representation on
screen
i know it's not always the big jumps
that we
that we want but i feel like it's
starting